that was on set with Melissa McCarthy
and her co-stars as they all tried to
come to grips with saying goodbye do any
of you have like a specific momentum
that you know you want to take with you
to help remember the show we've already
stolen so much have a car go man Zach
and you can't stop me yeah I looked
around the living room the other day and
I thought mmm just not my taste sure
there was some joking but after six
years together this happened oh those
tears started flowing as the gravity of
having to shoot Monday's finale started
to set in I think now we're just like
trying to get through it but tomorrow is
gonna be the show ends with a baby for
Mike and moment the woman that is having
our baby is having our baby what was
your reaction the first time that you
read the script for this pilot I like
that they had real jobs that he wasn't a
cop by day and like a superhero at night
which I love those two and I'm available
but I like that I was like I know these
people I've got cops in my family I just
bought it all it just all seemed easy
the first week we were at Melissa's
house just reading the script together I
mean we sat in her living room and we're
just reading it cuz we want everybody
work oh yeah yeah really for Hearst
about a house before the room we did we
will leave the way we started with Jace
yes this place we're not only proud of
the work I'm really honored to have
these people as friends